In the seminal March 2011 blog post, the rise and
fall of HL7, Australian standards guru,
Graham Greaves said that, complicated standards can be pushed for a while, but
ultimately markets reject them. He then goes on to essentially say that,
RIM is doomed because it is too complex. No single model will work in
all domains. It's internally inconsistent, which is often true of
extremely complex constructs, and ultimately it's too expensive to implement.
He pointed to JSON web services, Java, Java script object notation is
a light weight data interchange format that's easy for humans to read and
write. It's also easy for machines to parse and generate. The result,
some three years later, is FHIR, Fast Health Interoperability Resources.